[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants
j'espère que vous avez été sage
aujourd'hui me oui oui patron trop sage
alors je propose que nous fassions tous
ensemble un beau concert oui au contre
eur moore mais oui un vrai concert nous
jouerons chacun d'un instrument de
musique différents
de quels instruments s'est tu jouais mon
gros nounours
patron je suis trop musiciens
ma soeur rebbie yade s'est toujours quel
dommage que tu n'aies pas faim le
conservatoire nounours rogers peu mais
pas de pianiste
oui mais elles sont un petit peu saleté
tu ferais bien délavé le bon je veux
alors d'accord nous commençons à jouer
dès que pimprenelle nicholas hill
nounours sont prêts bonsoir
adieu la noce à la salle de sport où le
nom il paraît que mes pattes sont sales
ou plus lors
[Musique]
oh
il a raison la mi-mars jacques zam
et bien maintenant les enfants on va
faire de la musique tomie shiga
tu sais nounours je crois qu'on commence
à savoir bien jouer du pipeau
depuis c'est marrant aussi attention le
concert va commencer vous êtes l
musiciens on est prêt
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
[Musique]
oh
e
[Applaudissements]
on
au bond
oh
[Musique]
oh oh oh
oh
[Musique]
à
bravo le genre on bref on nous recevons
pas tu as l'air plutôt content of haut
la musique
le musée tu viennes des câlins on va se
coucher
je vous accompagne les enfants
au menu le musique belle ninon boni
quand les siens peu de nuit
ce petit la lutte pas là
[Musique]
faites court
bonne nuit mais comme ma peau nue pas
preneur quand bien
[Musique]